so Kelly you know we all shop online but
I have to you know there's some sites
that you know and you use a lot and you
they usually already have your credit
card stored and I use those but every
now and then I buy things from sites
that I might not be as familiar with and
it's a little bit scary because as as we
all know we don't want random people
running around with our credit card
information or more
how do you think about that how what
what safeguards or how what we should be
thinking in the back of our minds when
we're shopping
yeah I agree it's challenging because
you can't you know ideally you'd start
with somewhere you trust but that isn't
always an option
um I think that first off think about
something like https that will tell you
not that they're necessarily a safe
shopping site but at least that any
information you share is going to them
basically saying that the site like
traffic between you and the site is
encrypted so that you know that the site
is the the only people getting it
um another thing to think about is you
know do you have to share your credit
card information so a lot of banks now
are doing what we call virtual credit
card numbers so those are basically a
throwaway one-time number that they'll
give you where if it ever gets lost or
charges against it that you don't want
um you it's it's not your normal credit
card number so you can kind of get rid
of it and it's the damage is limited to
that fake one virtual one so uh browsers
like Chrome and and also Android have
built-in features to actually take
advantage of this and make it easy for
you to input your virtual number instead
of your regular credit card number
this is helpful I thought I was actually
pretty Savvy I didn't know about these
virtual credit card numbers I have to
figure out how to get to get some of
this super helpful thanks so much Kelly
sure